[Música]
como lo estábamos adelantando con
nuestra cronista de salud doma romeros a
la vamos entonces a pasar a hablar con
nuestra primera invitada del día de la
liberación de estas patentes de la
vacuna contra el eco bit 10 y no hay
pues todas las implicaciones que trae
esto para nuestra salud para ello
entonces saludamos a danna garcía al
test ellos doctora en medicina y cirugía
de la universidad autónoma de barcelona
con maestría en salud pública presidenta
la asociación de economía de la salud en
españa gracias ahora por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
mar hola muy buenos días también
cuéntenos cuáles el gran logro no
hablemos primero de las cosas positivas
de esta decisión a la que se llegó
pero primero de todo da las gracias de
que contéis conmigo y con la asociación
a la que representa para estar aquí con
vosotros un placer
a ver ahora diré una obviedad pero la
pandemia es un problema solo pública
mundial y hasta que no logremos vacunar
a toda la población esto no va a acabar
piensan que yo hoy estoy en una reunión
de la comisión europea en que hablamos
de kobe está existente
hay países donde hay cubierta existente
países donde conviven el consistente con
el cob y digamos activo y países donde
todo es todavía kobe está activo porque
no están vacunados por lo tanto la
vacunación es esencial para poder acabar
con la pandemia y además evitar de este
modo que el virus el coronavirus mute y
aparezcan todavía variantes más
peligrosas
esto no ha acabado todavía entonces
importantísimo poder aumentar la
producción de dosis de la vacuna
y lo que se ha visto es que nos
digamos que no damos abasto
básicamente porque se retiene la patente
retiene el derecho de fabricación con lo
cual liberarlo es muy importante
además como bien decía a marc lo
expuesto muy bien
las vacunas yo diga que todas ellas
directa o indirectamente algunas
directamente mucho otras indirectamente
han tenido financiación pública con lo
cual abrirá esa patente tiene todo el
sentido nosotros hecho con dinero
público vamos a de ser para todos
claro yo ahora quería aprovechar para
recordar unas cifras modernas recibió
más de 950 millones de dólares de dinero
público para su vacuna jansen 910
millones
fisher 800 millones decir que no estamos
hablando de cantidades pequeñas pero
pasemos a la siguiente pregunta y es que
hay organizaciones que han dicho que
este acuerdo no es suficiente primero
por no incluir medicamentos o
medicamentos o tratamientos y luego
porque estos mismos acuerdos están
teniendo límites de producción nos
podría resumir un poco cuáles cree que
son estas limitaciones que tiene el
acuerdo
el tema es de que esto es como tener una
receta puede ser una receta pero mejor
si no tienes la cazuela
el fogón y el aceite no puedes hacer no
la comida que sabe hacer
con lo cual a pesar de que se libere mos
de esa receta por decirlo así
hace falta inversión en equipos
calificados a veces en infraestructuras
en tecnologías emergentes no son los
algunas no son algo fácil de hacer y
menos todavía estas que van con esta
tecnología a rn que son especialmente
complejas por lo cual por más que tengas
la receta puede ser que aún así no sea
suficiente como para ponerte a fabricar
claro doctora anna también se lo estaba
comentando anteriormente a más romeros a
las íes en la siguiente pregunta si este
acuerdo realmente llega ya demasiado
tarde digamos en cuanto a la vacuna
contra contra la enfermedad de covite 19
no porque pues teniendo en cuenta que ya
la pandemia está terminando y llega esta
patente y pues de estos estos países no
tendrían como dice ustedes los
ingredientes para realizar esta receta
pues que es tan tarde ha llegado a este
acuerdo a más
concordancia con el pronunciamiento de
el presidente la organización de la cruz
roja internacional
si seguramente ha llegado tarde a ese
pues estábamos conversando con la
doctora anna garcía al test pues
obviamente esta liberación de las
patentes de la vacuna contra el cob y 19
se nos ha caído la comunicación pero
pues vamos a ver si podemos retomar la
conversación que ya no sé si tiene una
fuente para mientras la que mientras
estabas mientras estabas haciendo la
pregunta que esta pandemia se estaba
terminando y la verdad yo creo que
deberíamos decir eso entre comillas yo
voy a ponerle mucha precaución esa
afirmación porque no estamos seguros y
otra cosa que estaba mencionando también
la doctora y podemos aprovechar para
mencionar mientras tanto es ese tema de
la producción de que no se da abasto no
recordemos que si hay 5 farmacéuticas
que hacen la vacuna es muy distinto a
sixto la pueden producir farmacéuticas
de todo el mundo y sobre todo porque
recordemos que muchísimos países que ya
están aplicando terceras cuartas dosis
de refuerzo en españa se aprobó por
ejemplo recientemente la cuarta dosis de
refuerzo de la vacuna entonces digamos
que así la pandemia no esté en esos
primeros
como lo recordamos por ejemplo de hace
dos años eso no quita que todavía sean
muy importante estas vacunas para ir
pudiendo reforzar la inmunización de la
población no en áfrica 17 por ciento de
la población vacunada pero con las
primeras dosis no digamos con las
primeras dosis completas sin ningún
refuerzo sabemos que la inmunidad va
disminuyendo con el tiempo también
entonces pues podría ser que todos estos
esfuerzos sirvan al final en nada si no
se refuerzan claro mari y también como
lo estábamos comentando pues este
acuerdo realmente como también en la
obesidad de la autora y como lo dijo
también el presidente de precios de la
cruz roja internacional y la media luna
roja pues este acuerdo si llega pues un
poco tarde teniendo en cuenta que ya
esta solicitud venía del año 2020 por
parte de estos países sudáfrica creo que
era uno de estos países que también
estaban pidiendo esta liberación de las
patentes también hay muchas preguntas
sobre si esta decisión marca bueno ya ya
me dicen que tenemos a la doctora anna
sí
bueno entonces la otra pregunta mar no
sé si si si la tiene usted si yo quería
hacerle una pregunta y sobre todo es a
futuro no que elecciones nos deja este
acuerdo esto podría servir para futuras
crisis para futuras momentos en los que
se necesiten estos fármacos sin patentes
o tocará volver a decidir todo de nuevo
hombre y hay mucho trabajo adelantado
estoy sentamos un precedente de alguna
manera haciendo esto con lo cual si
hubieran futuras oportunidades es se
puede revisar lo hecho y en seguir
adelante por supuesto
de hecho también queríamos preguntarle
porque usted lo apuntaba no faltan
además de la receta faltan muchas otras
cosas que cosas particularmente crean
que pueden servir para mejorar la
autonomía de regiones del sur global
para hacer frente a las crisis de salud
pues más inversión en tecnología y en
innovación para que sean países
autónomos en cuanto a la producción de
estas vías en las vacunas fármacos
etcétera etcétera hace falta más
inversión en investigación y desarrollo
y ellos dar a estos países para que
puedan producir por sí mismos como cómo
lograr que estos países tengan menos
dependencia de los países desarrollados
para poder ser un poco más autónomos y
que estas decisiones pues no les afecten
lo tarde que lleguen por así decirlo
pues que inviertan por sí mismos más en
investigación y desarrollo como decía de
manera que puedan tener tanto el
conocimiento como la tecnología como las
infraestructuras
para ser capaces de hacer la producción
de estas estas vacunas o medicamentos o
lo que sea doctora pero también habíamos
visto que hay algunas de las
farmacéuticas que habían hecho como
acuerdos bilaterales para reducir el
precio de sus medicamentos lo que habían
hecho algunas estrategias para hacer una
transferencia de economía algunos shows
por ejemplo montados por la organización
mundial de la salud esto realmente es un
parche para una solución rápida o
realmente es una estrategia que puede
ser útil y marte agregó también el
doctor a qué pena qué pena antes de que
nos responda preguntar si también está
falta de conocimiento por parte de estos
países afectaría la seguridad de la
vacuna
creo que nos quedamos otra vez y nos
hemos preguntado más discúlpame como
para empezar no sé si todas esas
estrategias que habían logrado algunas
farmacéuticas
han logrado o sea es un parche fue
realmente una solución a largo plazo
es algo útil es algo lo que pasa es que
estos recuerdos a los que se han llegado
o sea cuesta un montón es difícil que
las empresas farmacéuticas se pongan de
acuerdo
para producir
algo en común o sea es algo que si si
esto tuviera que repetirse
cuando tú decías que hemos aprendido
bueno hemos aprendido que esto se puede
hacer pero en caso de que tuviéramos que
volver a repetir
deberíamos empezar desde cero hacer una
acuerdos bilaterales de compañías es
algo extremadamente costoso que empresas
distintas se pongan de acuerdo